wow
damn we do jock straps no that wasn't a
video let's put that to bed
hi i'm gladia delore i play hector in
the movie the end of us i'm claudia
streppo and i'm a producer and i'm ben
coleman and i play nick i'm derek and i
play tim i'm ali vigiano and i play leah
in the end of us before we made this
movie we worked at buzzfeed and today
we're going to be watching some of our
most iconic buzzfeed videos
guys try spanx for a day what's going on
here getting off i'm done with this you
win yeah all right i'll take that was
this our first video together ben i
think it was a series of videos around
this time this one and then guys try the
most painful face masks and the duck
straps wow
damn we do jock straps no that wasn't a
video
it is funny that a lot of buzzfeed
videos were like men do a crazy thing
that women do every day the idea of men
having to conceptualize
how women live their lives
and it did create a lot of
content i remember i quit before
everybody else did it was uncomfortable
all day i couldn't focus on anything
i've grown comfortable like i don't even
notice that i'm wearing them right now
yeah you're not wearing no spanx around
here no i'm not a little transparency i
really hated going to the bathroom at
work
it was a mission to find my favorite
bathroom and so i was like well this
should just be a video i need a video so
i wrote this directed it
in the in one day young derrick young
jared
it looks like you someone just died
someone's about to die
i thought buzzfeed was like disneyland
you know it was just like we were like
giving the keys to the car signs are
turning into a latino desk oh my god
early one
what was this like your second video i
think it was one of the early
[Laughter]
one shot a little text a bell sound
effect that's it damn this is really fun
you're so good this is so weird watching
that
this one was if bridesmaids were honest
oh a sleeveless dress for an outdoor
wedding at night
in the mountains it won't be cold
i don't hate my hair here but as time
went on it got worse and worse it's so
expensive to keep up color and so i um
couldn't afford to go to a good colorist
i hated those dresses it was so
uncomfortable and it fits it see it like
squished my boobs and it was like way
too tight you look great i hated
written and directed by stephen cantor
who also is one of the writer directors
on the end of us thanks good to uh it's
good to see you you guys look very happy
it's cool and starring ben and derek my
my two love interests in the end of us
and claudia purple hair
baby ben baby derek dude this but like
the style that we made this is very
similar to how we went about the end of
us also we were drinking red wine and by
the end of this video you can definitely
see that we were starting to feel it
was so good yeah
devin listening molly drugs oh my god
does derek have a
tinfoil in his ear
oh he like made an earring yeah
this is actually really good oh this one
wow the respect and credit that it
deserves
let's put that to bed
thank you buzzfeed that was actually
super fun make sure you check out the
end of us in theaters december 3rd
[Music]